en 2021 les entreprises françaises
cotées en bourse ont réalisé des profits
records des chiffres historiques pour
certaines bnp paribas affiche 9 5
milliards d'euros de bénéfices 16,1 pour
cent de plus qu'en 2010 9 tandis que
lvmh a engrangé 12 milliards d'euros
ainsi que 6,3 milliards pour sanofi est
totale à total rebaptisé total energy ou
plurielle pour être moins catalogué
pétrole énergies fossiles et bien la
compagnie a engrangé 15 milliards c'est
le montant le plus haut depuis 15 ans en
tout on parle de prévisions de 137
milliards d'euros de profits en 2021 71
% de plus qu'en 2019 mais pas de quoi
pavoiser cette réussite s'appuie bien
sûr le rebond attendu après la mort aux
années 2020 est également largement sur
les aides de l'état la france a ainsi
accordé 240 milliards aux sociétés via
les aides et le plan de relance dont une
partie a été dirigée vers ces grandes
entreprises lesquels pour la plupart se
sont empressés de verser des dividendes
à leurs actionnaires
alors même que la ministre du travail
mme muriel pénicaud hab et inciter à la
retenue il faut aussi considérer que les
aides massives étaient assorties de
contreparties en matière de partage des
richesses de protection de l'emploi de
l'environnement alors que de nombreuses
entreprises du cac 40 ont engagé des
plans sociaux ou non licenciés mais
revenons sur un cadre d'écoles total
énergie à cause de la flambée des prix
du baril du gaz les os des factures
d'énergie de carburant sont une tragédie
pour certains consommateurs saluons
alors le geste noble de total qui s'est
sacrifié patrick pouyanné son pdg a
annoncé un chèque de 100 euros pour 200
mille ménages précaires et 5 euros de
réduction pour un plein de 50 litres
dans mille 150 stations services en zone
rurale mais seulement pendant trois mois
vous êtes trop bon monseigneur sauf que
cette petite elle est en réalité une
tartufferie elles représentent moins de
0 4 % des bénéfices engrangés par total
et cela ne passe pas chez les ong
environnementales ni chez les politiques
totalement que les prix de l'essence en
caisse 15 milliards de profits et parce
qu'il fait une opération de pub à 5
euros offerts pour 50 des pensées il
faut lui dire merci ça va pas la tête ça
me fait penser aux voleurs kitt peak ta
voiture mais torrent l'allume-cigare le
bénéfice net de total et de monsieur
puyané ces 15 milliards d'euros cette
année sur le dos des françaises et des
français les factures de gaz et
d'essence qui augmente c'est au profit
des actionnaires les ristournes promises
par total leur coûteront 50 millions
d'euros soit 0 33 % de leurs 15
milliards de bénéfices et il faudrait se
mettre à genoux mains jointes merci pour
le mode monseigneur non blocage des
dividendes blocage des prix ces 15
milliards d'euros sont à nous et les
politiques de tickets sur les dividendes
redistribués par total energy 7,1
milliards à ses actionnaires en 2021
soit la moitié du profit réalisé les
entreprises du cac 40 aurait distribué
aux actionnaires près de 70 milliards
d'euros en 2021 sous forme de dividendes
ou de rachats d'actions un record
historique
mais les salariés aurait-il bénéficier
d'une quelconque largesses au vu de ces
profits pharamineux et bien sans
surprise pas vraiment total qui comptait
supprimer plusieurs centaines de postes
en france fin 2020 a bien augmenté les
salaires de 3 5% en 2022 par exemple
mais pour les moins payés cette hausse
conséquente n'est pas significative bnp
n'a augmenté ses employés que de 0,6
pour cent préférant accorder des primes
et intéressement en fait la théorie du
ruissellement c'est merveilleux c'est
juste que dans une formidable offense à
la gravité le liquide remonte
massivement vers le haut vers les plus
riches laissant les millions de pauvres
à sec